[Music]
chris is with us in Indiana hi Chris how
are you I'm good how are you better than
I deserve what's up well my in-laws
approached my wife and I thinking of
giving us a large percentage of what
would be our inheritance from them here
in the next you know couple of years or
sooner I guess their fear is that you
know if they go into a nursing home or
some types some situation like that that
that would soak up a lot of those
resources and I just I had some poems
about it you know it's their money
mm-hmm I wanted to get your thoughts
doesn't work okay when you cannot make
yourself look broke when you're not
broke in order to get the nursing home
provided by the government on welfare
government free nursing home from the
government is for welfare it's for broke
people and if you if you move your
assets out of your name the governor the
government can look back five years on
some things and ten years on the other
and disqualify you from getting free
nursing home care you don't qualify from
for welfare because you gave all your
money away yeah that's what amounts to
it's called fraud they call it I don't
fare fraud that's what the government
calls it and they will come down on
their head if they find all of this and
they'll look back five years and if they
smell a rat they can go back ten years
and so their their motivation for doing
this is wrong how old are they just in
their late 60s tell them to go get
long-term care insurance okay that takes
care of their nursing home bill and you
know here's the thing the nursing home
bills are not I mean they're bad if
you're broke but how much money these
people got oh I just think it'd be on
the order of a hundred thousand I am NOT
under speculating they've not given me
any kind of real numbers and they need
to get long-term care insurance
immediately and it's going to cost them
you know twenty five hundred thirty five
hundred dollars a year it's worth every
penny
of it to protect their money but no they
do not need to transfer assets in order
to falsely qualify for welfare it's not
only morally wrong it's legally wrong
and the government will come down on
them if they catch them doing it and
they do look at this stuff
and the average nursing home stay is
only about three years so it would eat
up a hundred grand okay if they did go
into the nursing home and don't have
long-term care insurance but most
long-term care insurance policies now
cover about three years of nursing home
care so I would spend the money on
long-term care insurance and I would go
get it today if I was in this situation
I would not try to hide assets to
falsely qualify for welfare
you were right to feel funny about this